[Musica]
ciao
bentornate solito stress oggi a
grandissima richiesta dalle tantissime
lo state chiedendo ci ho messo un po a
far comprare la mano finalmente apple a4
madame de rendendo il corso shopping gol
che ho fatto
vado a fare lo slime con questa mano
finita
non so come sia secondo voi cuffia un
disastro o finalissima scrivete nei
commenti vediamo chi indovina il più
affine video voglio togliere la pelle a
questa mano spero non mi fara troppo
impressione con la mano mentre impazza e
come questa è la sua tenuta in like a
questo video di simile likes andrò a
fare un'altra cella di spazza
consegnatemi pure quella tavolette nei
commenti
i ragazzi che pronti patatine pop corn
iniziamo stati tutto
la prima cosa che ripetere la colla io
qua o là trasparente però ho paura che
la bottiglia sia troppo grande
vediamo perché non riesce o non esce
bene stringerla io spero solo che non
cada tutto sul tavolo non dieci come
recuperarlo adesso un dramma no ragazzi
non ce l'ho fatta crollato alla
trasparente proviamo con la colombiana
in questa bottiglia fini dovrebbe essere
più facile prenderla io spero solo di
non può accadere tutto l'estro fatta
wow di grip dovuto vedere il tappo
adesso spetta la forza di tempo dai
sensi togliere il tappo
adesso la mano chi si addormenta in
questa posizione
maledetto siedi al è possibile togliere
questa mala quindi niente dello stretto
abbiamo la colla primo tempo e ci siamo
riusciti
ora dobbiamo mettere di colorante ho già
perso tempo fa sarebbe stato impossibile
brano svegliami succedendo
[Musica]
incredibile quando volete fare lo sterno
ma non volete sporcarvi le mani
basta usare una mano finta simon aprilia
mentre lui può perché voglio che questi
splendidi 20 fucsia rosa bello accesso
può quindi ne metto un bel posto con un
colore acrilico dopo avrà che cartone
[Musica]
per ora sta accendendo il colore molto
bene oggi che disappunto verso no vabbè
basta
grazie assistette d'amico di scott e io
volevo solo far sempre più buffa che è
diventato un colorante con colla o tra
l'altro la massa è già sporcata spero di
riuscire a recuperarlo dopo e prima
pulirla paolo scotti oddio bitter questi
viola
se questi ce ne yo no dai prendere vai
tu sporcando tutto siamo quasi
si no
una fuga
[Musica]
no ragazzi non posso più toglierla sono
mi sporco ancora di più la mano mi
dispiaceva che il barattolino farà parte
dello spray malles
non posso farci niente aprendo un'altra
un barattolino di grizzetti davvero in
compenso è sembrata rino times
ora possiamo provare a mettere allora
volevo mettere queste palline ma non ne
sono più sicura perché ho paura che che
avrà tutto sul tavolo mentre la schiuma
da barba alla sapienza petr cech
guardate sembra che lunghi o lo
smartphone i blink che cosa quanto
sempre ora in realtà io ho compreso la
spatola per mischiare ma non so se
mischiare direttamente con la mafia che
così sporca proviamo dovremo un po con
la spatola se non ho paura che succeda
un casino
allora mi riguarda non fredde sono quasi
scatta dalla stringer proprio quindi
dovrà me dovrò mischia il tutto con la
mano siete pronti guardate un po è
stranissimo comunque ha dei bellissimi
colori magari esce bene tranne la
boccetta di great aspetta molto
no perché ti cappato mi dispiace se
permessi resta criticata non metteremo
detto a prenderla scivola dai su la
posso fare
ci tengono sotto la collana mano i
primati receiver toccherà ho cercato di
pulirla ma allora aspetta prima fila tra
le dita perché l'impatto potenza questa
cosa perché l'ho preso prima
proviamo del bicarbonato
[Musica]
soprattutto no non scivolare a due
all'ora l'apertura ed a questa parte
quindi lo spreco d'acqua tipo sancisce
[Musica]
ha detto ora mancante alla soluzione
perfetti devo trovare un metodo il
metodo per ogni volta a volare dott
non mi aspettavo che facesse per farci
wow 60 l'unica cosa che mi viene in
mente è cercare di raccogliere la
correttezza ho un'idea la prendono una
boccetta tipo questa me la metto dentro
[Musica]
parate
[Applauso]
[Musica]
allora non dire di no e basta
ragazzi questo gesto semplice vedete non
ho sporcato niente quando usate la mano
finta non sporcate in mente per farlo
slice portate neanche le parimenti ha
dovuto nella ciotola wow che si sta
formando trasformando è difficilissimo e
anche bello ma è molto faticoso
mischiare con la mano finto ma
l'importante è che stia funzionando
ragazzi non ho idea di come staccarlo
dalla mano però è un fighetto proviamo a
fare un po di punti con la mano finita
anche se arriva sotto incollato vediamo
tanto ormai può farlo è andato ma è in
condizioni ormai di pietro per quindi
scivola a prestazione
ci sentiamo le mr dallamano finta
non male però siccome siamo qua dove in
sostanza caldo ok azzeravano a prenderlo
con l'altra mia vera mano e l'idea un po
come il sito ha per fortuna si stacca a
porta
il fronte rettore l'autore twitter
dentro c'erano pezzi incastrato sotto lo
stand con i click
forse ho messo troppo bicarbonato però
non è nel maggio del colore mi piace un
sacco si vedano anche di te vediamo come
gesto mr non male devo dire pensavo
molto peggio guardate qua il clipper che
sono rivolti orale posso aggiungere
[Musica]
wow
questo ci sembra proprio un bubblegum
devo dire che è uscito abbastanza bene
mi aspettavo molto peggio
proviamo ora a fare il booking marchio
va beh
dai un po esse sezione allora che voto
di dati a questo sliven fatto con la
morbida da una 10 io pensavo molto molto
peggio
voglio trovare sentire qualche suono smr
e poi apriamo la mano cioè gli togliamo
la pelle che carino mi disse che si
vedono cyclette bellissimo sono contenta
che è un sito mi piace un sacco il
colore
ora siete pronti
chissà come detto chiediamo allora
innanzitutto fa penso k s perché lo sto
spiegando poi che questo materiale di
coma spa strappati pelle vera
detto questo non si muove infatti sono
spot di classica tutti un robot che
strano notte come la vita sembra un
robot malefico adesso vogliamo muoverla
[Musica]
cosa ne pensate della mano tutta pelle
nel bsb con la pelle o senza voglia di
sapere nei commenti serie che accetta
questa challenge se volete che faccia
qualcos'altro di simile che tipo di
strano in questa pazza con la mano
pincha oppure consigliato di tutte le
prossime challenge nei commenti era
rilassata 4 katherine e poi potete
cliccare 1234 scegliete quello che
perché l'inter per vedere i prossimi
video e buona visione